[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com I want to start today with a
very well-done Yahoo News investigation
which reveals that the entire Seth rich
conspiracy theory from a couple of
really I guess three years ago at this
point was planted and fomented by
Russian intelligence and this is a
pretty stunning and particularly
disturbing revelation because of how
successful this conspiracy theory was I
mean remember this conspiracy theory
penetrated not only the rights but even
some enclaves of left-wing media the the
wackier elements admittedly but it did
get into the left as well and the idea
of this conspiracy theory and again as I
often say with these things if this is
news to you if you didn't even hear
about the fact that this was actually
getting some traction I envy you I wish
I had never heard about the fact that
this was going on but the theory was
that Seth rich a DNC staffer was not
actually killed in a robbery gone wrong
but rather by Associates of Hillary
Clinton because he simply knew too much
possibly about Hillary's emails or
hacking of the DNC emails which wasn't
really actually what it was claimed to
be or because of Hillary's corruption
that he knew about and that he was
killed in July of 2016 in order to
ensure his silence and that what he knew
would never go public including through
WikiLeaks with whom he was allegedly
according to some flavours of the
conspiracy in touch right after the
incident in which rich was killed in
July of 2016
the SVR which is Russia's Foreign
Intelligence Service started fomenting
the idea that this was not as reported
not a robbery gone wrong but instead it
was because he was Seth rich was just so
close to telling the FBI or WikiLeaks or
whoever
about all of the corrupt dealings of
Hillary Clinton so he was killed the
truth of course is that rich was killed
when walking home from a bar in
Washington DC he was on the phone with
his girlfriend at the time and he was
shot twice in the back of the head and
an element of the story that is
sometimes included is that there were
these connections with Julian Assange's
WikiLeaks and then after the SVR
initially participated in creating this
conspiracy the internet research agency
which is this Russian troll factory
which we've talked about before which
engages in social media disinformation
campaigns started aggressively
circulating the conspiracy and getting
it more auction and of course we know
that it was eventually spread by allies
of Donald Trump including Roger stone
Steve Bannon said it was a quote
contract kill obviously end quote
Trump attorney Jay Sekulow said it quote
sure doesn't look like a robbery Sean
Hannity ended up running with it we saw
Alex Jones talk about it I believe I'm
going from memory now and then even some
elements of the left were spreading this
conspiracy theory shockingly I'm not
even going to name them you can research
them that's interesting to you
now I don't even know that I need to
point out some of the problems with the
conspiracy theory there are many but
I'll include just a few one being the
big picture that Seth rich was merely a
data analyst he didn't have access to
nor the technical know-how to hack and
access what he would have needed to
access his parents have corroborated
that he didn't have the knowledge
there's no evidence that's been found
that Seth rich had any information that
he was in contact with anybody at
WikiLeaks to whom he would have sent
that information but it doesn't matter
because the propagators of this will
continue to believe it and try to
propagate it and they are already even
saying that the Yahoo News report
pointing to Russian intelligence as
fomenting this conspiracy is part of the
planted fake backstory meant to take
attention away from the fact that this
was a contract kill or a murder meant to
silence Seth rich now in fact the fourth
richest family this has been terrible
okay a Seth Rich's parents have repeated
we ask that people just stop that the
conspiracies are like quote losing him
all over again they've said so the real
story for me here is that there's a huge
overlap between those who fell for the
seth rich conspiracy theory and those
who believe that Russia did nothing to
attack our election systems or to help
Donald Trump lots of Seth rich
conspiracists also see the Russia story
as a completely fabricated one Seth rich
conspiracists are often also Russia
deniers and it turns out that it's the
same Russian forces that claim that they
like to say did nothing at all with
regard to the election that were
actually the ones pushing this Seth rich
conspiracy theory in front of more and
more people now if you're wondering why
is it and Russia's interest to push such
a conspiracy theory it's the same reason
that it's in their interest to do
everything that they've done it's
consistent with Russia's desire to
foment chaos and destabilize basic
democratic systems and spreading the
notion that one of the presidential
candidates might have had someone killed
before they could blow the whistle on
them if that is believed it contributes
to this chaotic perception or this
perception that American democracy is an
absolute and total chaos and of course
in a sense it is 60 million people voted
for Donald Trump and that is
extraordinarily chaotic but not in the
way that these conspiracies seek to make
people believe it is truly sick to use a
family's tragedy to try to advance a
political agenda with a completely bogus
conspiracy theory it's sick for Russian
intelligence to do it it's sick for
American media to do it Fox News the
elements of the left Alex Jones whoever
else and most importantly it's really
important that we just kind of be adults
about this stuff when it comes to oh
you're either a Russia conspiracist or a
Russia denier and everything is
completely black and white Russia like
many countries has intelligence services
they have geopolitical priorities that
they determine what they believe to be
the best ways to try to encourage the
United States
does a ton of this stuff in other
countries this is not unique to Russia I
have not really met anybody that I
consider serious that has this sort of
horse blinders black/white view of
Russia is uniquely bad evil whatever or
Russia is simply a there's nothing to
see here whatsoever mostly the people
that are actually thoughtfully thinking
about this stuff that might be an
oxymoron thoughtfully thinking that are
actually thinking about this stuff
critically see Russia as one of many
countries that has intelligence
operations and intelligence operatives
all over the world and they happen to
have been more successful than many
other countries over the last three to
five years that's basically it and
jumping into these very black wide the
the black/white thinking that pervades a
lot of people's minds every time Russia
is mentioned is destructive and also
counterproductive it's getting worse and
worse for Donald Trump now that Jeffrey
Epstein has been arrested for child sex
trafficking I told you before and I
reminded you yesterday that a woman has
alleged that when she was 13 years old
Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein raped
her at Epstein's New York City condo the
lawsuit was ultimately stopped by the
accuser after she allegedly received
death threats because she had come
forward now Donald Trump has been going
very much out of his way to distance
himself from Jeffrey Epstein as much as
possible despite having hung out with
him a lot in years past and he even
threw out somebody at his rally in
Minnesota over the weekend for holding
up a picture of Trump with his arm
around Jeffrey Epstein I talked about
that yesterday there's now a stunning
report in The New York Times which
includes the story of a 1992 party at
Donald Trump's mar-a-lago Resort in
Florida where the only attendees were
Donald Trump
Jeffrey Epstein and quote 28 girls for
some kind of supposed calendar girl
competition now why am i calling them
girls and not women because that's the
word that the organizer used to describe
this event his name is George her a knee
he's a Florida businessman who ran
American dream enterprise and he
organized this
for Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein
saying to the New York Times quote I
arranged to have some contestants fly in
at the very first party I said who's
coming tonight I have 28 girls coming it
was him and Epstein I said Donald this
is supposed to be a party with VIPs
you're telling me it's you and Epstein
and I want to be really really careful
here to make clear what I am Telling You
and what I am not telling you or what it
is that the New York Times is reporting
and what it is not that they're
reporting there is no indication that
any of these 28 women were underage as
far as what we know right now okay this
is evidence that Donald Trump was truly
friends with Epstein liked Epstein liked
hanging out with him was hanging out
with him and in this case it was just
him Epstein and 28 hired women or girls
as they are described by George her Amy
so the big picture is very clear the
party was in 1992 this is around the
same time that the doe versus Trump
incident allegedly happened where Trump
was accused of raping the
thirteen-year-old girl I got some emails
yesterday from people saying David I'm
glad you brought this back up but I also
got a few emails yesterday saying David
why are you repeating these
unsubstantiated conspiracy theories
against Trump well hold on a second
there are rape allegations the lawsuit
was pulled over death threats Trump is
accused of sexually assaulting more than
15 women
he's accused of hanging out with Epstein
and young women Trump's wife said that
Trump raped her multiple times
what is so out of line here about the
fact that we have court documents and
deposition testimony from the accuser of
Donald Trump claiming she was 13 years
old when Donald Trump raped her are you
saying that because there was no
conviction in the Trump child rape there
is no reason to think anything happened
that seems like an extreme position to
take incredibly there are tons and tons
of people who just have no idea about
the sworn allegations against Donald
Trump but we have sworn statements from
the woman who was 13 at the time that
has not changed we are linking to her
deposition video where her face is
blurred in the source links
for the YouTube video for this segment
if you want to take a look at it if
you're listening on the radio or the
podcast or watching on TV if you go to
our YouTube channel youtube.com slash
the David Pakman show
find the video clip for this story in
the description we are linking to the
testimony of the accuser take a look at
it and tell me that it's not credible so
things not going particularly well for
Donald Trump and we will see what
continues to come of this and Donald
Trump very clearly worried about it
Donald Trump going out of his way to
talk about how he just barely has any
idea who Epstein is he gave a very
strange Oval Office question-and-answer
session yesterday where he's just going
way too far he's going way too far given
what we know and what's on record about
his relationship with Epstein let me
know what you think is going to come of
this and of course if history is an
indicator the last two and a half years
are an indicator it is unlikely that
there will ever actually be any
consequences that involve Trump here
because that seems to be the name of the
game Teflon Don originally I can't
believe the mobster I always forget who
it is that Teflon Don was originally the
nickname for and I feel so stupid when
people email me but anyway can also be
applied to Donald Trump send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
hope you'll follow me there the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com ok today's two new members of
the day supporting independent media
voting with their dollars deciding to
leave a tip as the case may be
Stefan Gunn and Grady Johnson Stefan and
Grady thank you for signing up and being
today's newest David Pakman show members
also want to say thank you to someone
who's been with us for almost five years
Tomi Garcia Tommy's been a member since
2014 going on just under five years of
membership and I really do appreciate
your support
join Steph and Grady and Tommy by
signing up takes under 60 seconds at WWJ
pakman.com the regular rates are
extraordinarily reasonable but I
understand that for some folks a
discount is preferable and you can pick
up that discount entering the coupon
code this is 20/20 into the coupon code
field when you sign up that'll chop 40%
off of the price of your membership but
you still get 100% of the benefits
including the world-famous bonus show
daily just for our paid subscribers as
well as commercial free audio and video
streams of the full one-hour show just
for you okay it's time for hatred mail
hatred mail of course when we hear from
the haters of the David Pakman show
their voicemails rather their emails
interpretive ly read by a professional
voice-over artist
[Music]
the right of the people to keep and bear
hates shall not be infringed patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom okay this is just someone who I
guess is is so angry with me that they
want me to do something that would be
really bad that I don't want to do and
I'm not going to do take a listen to
this David you are a sick deranged a
snowflake try suicide America will be
better off if you were dead any what you
[ __ ] weakling and take the tour who
birthed your loser ass to hell when you
go Germany has embraced Edie's Nazi past
and you add just another Jew hating Nazi
it's only a matter of time before all
you deranged illiberal socialists start
exterminating Jews all over Europe all
you suck your Muslim masters you smell
yeah so listen I don't I don't like the
joke about suicide so my only commentary
is if you are in a situation where you
are thinking of harming yourself or it
is something if you are in a situation
where you want to talk to someone please
be aware that the National Suicide
Prevention lifeline is available 24
hours a day okay the numbers 800 273
8255 this is serious business okay and
I'm not even going to indulge the
content of this hatred mail other than
to say I want everybody in the audience
to know that they can always talk to
someone the National Suicide Prevention
lifeline is available eight hundred two
seven three eight two five five . okay
that's it that's what I want everybody
to know so I've been flooded I mean
truly flooded with emails from viewers
about what is going on with YouTube
lately and this has gotten so big that
it is beyond the David Pakman show at
this point in time my recent coverage of
what's going on with YouTube has
actually been
voted and cited in a bunch of different
articles about what is taking place and
I am actually going to show you a few of
the emails I've gotten from viewers
which have confirmed to me that what's
going on is even worse than I thought
and I thought it was pretty bad now if
you miss the story on Monday the big
picture is that YouTube has changed
their algorithm over time but acutely
since the first day of May of this year
to drastically reduce the number of
recommendations that it makes for
viewers of YouTube to look at
independent news and politics channels
like this one or like sam cedars or like
kyle colon skis and has instead shifted
those recommendations to legacy
corporate youtube channel so CNN has a
youtube channel foxnews has a youtube
channel MSNBC likewise has a youtube
channel also shifting views from
independent channels like ours to the
youtube channels for these big
late-night talk shows produced by mega
corporations with thousands and
thousands of employees or even tens of
thousands of some of these huge mega
corporations i now have for you today an
absolutely devastating image that sums
this up in total okay so on Monday I
gave you some of the micro examples that
are powerful but they are anecdotal okay
so example number one I showed you the
recommendation numbers over time which
showed that at the same time that
recommended views to my channel and to
sam cedars and Kyle Cole in skis and
right wingers Steven Crowder's Channel
when those recommendations went down the
recommendations to CNN and Fox News and
MSNBC went up but of course there are
way more channels than just our four
channels and those three corporate media
channels and even if I can find a bunch
of these micro correlations we really
need more if we're going to make a
broader claim about what's going on with
YouTube and I now have it for you and it
is devastating Marc led which compiled
all of this data and built a tool to
visualize it and he sent this to me this
is not a channel by channel analysis
this is the aggregate of hundreds of the
major news and politics channels on
YouTube okay this analysis includes all
YouTube channels with 10,000 or more
subscriber
that have 30% or more of their content
as US politics or US cultural news and
commentary what you saw in the early
part of the year is that there was a
sort of balance around 40 to 50 percent
of YouTube's news and politics
recommendations were two independent
channels like mine and about 40 to 50
percent of YouTube's news and politics
recommendations were for what we call TV
cable legacy media that have YouTube
channels this includes CNN and Fox News
and MSNBC and then you see that at the
end of March and more acutely even at
the end of April beginning of May that
even 50/50 split imploded and lately 75
percent and climbing of YouTube's
recommended news and politics views are
legacy corporate TV cable channels while
only about twenty four and a half
percent and dropping of the
recommendations are left for all of the
independent channels to split amongst
ourselves so it's really important to
understand there are way fewer big
corporate cable TV YouTube channels so
when the few YouTube I'm sorry when the
few corporate cable TV channels are
splitting 75% of the recommendations and
a ton of independent channels are
splitting 25% of the recommendations the
degree of inequality is stunning and
this is the opposite of what YouTube
used to be this is terrible this data is
devastating and in the meantime the
individual video D monetization z' are
exploding this image we're putting up on
the screen is from yesterday three of
our first four videos were demonetized
as you can see by the yellow dollar sign
rather than the green dollar sign we
spent all day researching and producing
those three of them earn zero despite
getting lots of views some over a
hundred thousand views in the first 12
hours the Trump child rape 1 I
understand the others not so much now
for people who write in and say David
don't you have a YouTube representative
who can help you with what's going on I
do she's been telling me for three weeks
that she's quote waiting for more
information
historically that means that after a
month or two I'll get some kind of form
letter that communicates nothing about
you check out some of these emails from
the audience Nicole says hello just want
to say I'm not getting recommendations
for your videos from YouTube anymore
when I subscribed last year I would get
recommendations every day down to zero
now not a problem because I'm a member
and I'm watching the full show every day
still don't understand why YouTube
doesn't mention you anymore your show is
one of my favorites worth every penny
Phillipe says for the past few weeks I
noticed that there are fewer and fewer
of your daily videos showing up whenever
I type David Pakman in the search bar of
YouTube it shows lots of older videos
though but just two or three new videos
now just thought I'd point out my
experience if it can help you grit
says I am frequently watching the
following shows David Pakman ring of
fire secular talk and it looks like the
algorithm is specifically after your
show I have subscribed to your show on
YouTube and receive emails when you
upload new videos even so when I open a
new iniya window in YouTube the
recommendation line never includes your
show despite my frequent visit to your
YouTube page and watching it Samantha
says I'm constantly unsubscribed from
your channel on YouTube I've been
subscribed for years notice your videos
are gone go to your channel page and the
subscribe button is not pressed I click
it and subscribe for a few days then the
same thing again YouTube unsubscribes me
from your channel
Simon Says I've been a member in one way
or another for years I'm also a YouTube
premium subscriber and I listen to this
show and other progressive shows will
like commute or work at my office lately
I've had to constantly reopen the
YouTube app and find and click on your
videos after having just watched one
MSNBC has been popping up as the up next
video way more often than normal and
it's gotten really annoying
and lastly Michael says David after
watching your video I have to admit my
recommendation feed has been bothering
me a subscriber I don't see you Kyle or
Sam cedar the last two weeks have been
particularly horrible some folks have
written in and said David what about
just going to another platform I'm
invited to three alternative platforms
every week the problem is they have no
traffic they have no funding they have
terrible design and they have no
monetization so there's no actual
advantage to switching over to a
platform that earns no
and has no audience so here's the bottom
line okay
I think this is how we have to think
about shows at this point in time I am a
service worker we all are at the show
and who are at other shows that you
might watch or like we aren't producing
a physical product we're producing
something in the service space
it's like someone who works as a
bartender or cleaning houses or whatever
sometimes those jobs are paid with a
salary
sometimes they're paid hourly sometimes
in the United States there's the
expectation of tips which are of course
optional and we can evaluate whether a
tip makes sense so waitstaff at
restaurants for example they often make
263 an hour that's their hourly wage so
when I go out to eat I tip 20 percent
whenever I go out to eat I don't have to
I value their work and I think their
wage is too low so I choose to pay a 20%
tip in the same way you are under no
obligation to pay directly for shows
that you like we produce this show at
our expense for you we distribute it to
200 public radio and television stations
at our expense because we want to do
that that being said we have no
guaranteed wage from any of our
platforms we give the show to radio and
TV stations we put the show on YouTube
and many of the videos are d monetized
and earn no money there and YouTube's
changes are hurting us if we don't do
well in the tips meaning contributions
from you there is no backup we don't get
any experience or seniority raise from
the platforms that were on and in fact
the opposite has mostly been happening
over the year now I still give my
employees seniority raises and merit
raises and cost-of-living adjustments I
just eat those costs if you like the job
we are doing for you here think of us as
the wait staff or your bartender but
instead of being guaranteed some minimum
wage we're not so you can choose to
leave a few bucks a month and I don't
care if it's this show or others it's
about supporting the shows you think are
important and valuable there's two
really easy ways to do this get a
membership right on our website it takes
under a minute you get lots of extra
stuff but you are sort of tipping like
you would a waiter or a waitress the
normal prices I think are very
reasonable many of you have signed up in
the last month if you want a discount
but you can use the coupon code this is
2020 and get 40% off and I'll even go
further and tell you you can use the
coupon code half 19 1/2 19 and get 50%
off the other is throw us a buck or two
a month on patreon okay that's also easy
you go to patreon.com/scishow click the
orange become a patron button and that's
it you don't have to I understand if you
don't under one percent of the audience
supports us financially we're gonna keep
doing our thing okay but if you find it
valuable then I would appreciate it
let's disconnect our revenue from
advertising as much as possible and to
help us additionally without paying
anything make sure you are subscribed to
the YouTube channel like this video
share this video the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's my pleasure to welcome to the
program today ask for Taylor who is an
author and documentary filmmaker she's
the director of the film what is
democracy and also author of the book
democracy may not exist but we'll miss
it when it's gone great to talk to you I
appreciate it
hey thanks for having me so we've had
conversations before about what
democracy is should be and could be and
one of the conversations that often ends
up happening between the audience and me
after those interviews are these
questions about is direct democracy
really the only type of democracy that
we should be going for and questions
like that and I find that a little bit
less interesting than something you're
dealing with which is the idea of is it
really democracy if there is dark money
if there is disproportionate power by
kleptocrats and corporations and
people's and put people in positions of
power etc so just kind of start the
conversation has there ever been a
democracy and that could be a however we
choose to define it that was not in some
way influenced by those forces by which
many modern Western democracies are
influenced today it's an interesting
question I mean I've certainly been
involved in those debates you just laid
out right have you know is the only real
democracy direct and not you know not
using structures of representation and
and so that influence is a bit of the
work I'm doing but I tried to ask a
different kind of question actually I
wanted to shift perspective and to to
look at democracy as a process as an
ongoing project in a kind of ideal that
we're reaching towards and one of the
consistent things that has thwarted
people in their democratic aspirations
has been the problem of economic
inequality and this goes all the way
back to ancient
Riis so you know the ancient Athenians
didn't invent the practice of democracy
but they give us the word which comes
down to demos and Kratos the people hold
power or rule and even in those early
days which you know they didn't have a
system that you could describe as
capitalism right they didn't have a
modern industrial economy like like we
do but nonetheless they were very
attuned to the fact that inequalities of
wealth would subvert democracy and in
fact in the Republic which is you know
the famous anti-democratic text by Plato
where he famously warns that democracy
devolves into tyranny he says very
clearly that the underlying problem is
that the divide between the rich and the
poor grows to the point where it breaks
the city into where the rich want to get
richer and so they put poor people in
Tibet and the poor can't live anymore
and so that this creates conflict and
leads to the rise of demagogues and what
we would consider populism in today's
terms so I think with the problem of
economic inequality of something
democracies have to wrestle with and it
creates all sorts of problems for the
way our political system is structured
today
it in my book in in in the framing I use
what I say is that there are these
inherent tensions in democracy there why
democracy is hard is because it involves
contradictory elements right so the
local and the global and the question of
who's in and who's out and the question
how to balance the needs of the present
with the future but intense inequality
economic inequality just makes those
tensions almost you know unbearable and
really makes exacerbates problems that
we have to negotiate no matter what yeah
I when I'm reminded of when I read Jared
Diamond's book Guns Germs and Steel and
in it he talks about I think he divides
people as potentially organizing in four
different ways going from I think it's
individual villages like groups of
families relatively small and maybe the
second one is tribes then fiefdom x' and
then more sort of like nation-states or
something closer to what we have today
and once you get to the fiefdom x' and
the nation-states it's really difficult
to imagine circumstances in which there
is not going to be some inequality
either
be it economic or in terms of cultural
power which often comes from
disproportionate economic power now
there will be those who will hear us
talking and they'll say no you guys are
missing the reality that this is really
an economic conversation about socialism
versus capitalism and that you can have
a democracy that is far more equal if
not totally equal if you simply change
your system of government to one of
socialism but I actually think it's more
complicated than that I'm curious to
hear what you think about it well you
know in the preface to the book and
throughout I you know invoke the
socialist project right because I think
social is have played an incredibly
powerful role in advancing democracy as
we know it today I mean they were they
pushed for for suffrage for civil rights
all sorts of things I my my point is
that even in a system of economic
egalitarianism right so even if we were
able to close the gap between the rich
and the poor between owners and workers
right and and I personally have I have
an imagination that allows me to imagine
that I mean just like a hundred years
ago someone might say hey masters and
slaves that's just natural that's how it
always is you know now we say hey
there's makers and takers there's rich
and poor that's how it always is I
personally can imagine a world where
we've closed that gap but because we
know that we know some countries have
far less why hold degrees of inequality
than the United States today so you know
I think we could do a lot to to lift
people up and bring other people down to
a sane level we don't need a world where
we don't need a country where three
billionaires have as much wealth as half
of the population and so the thing I'm
trying to say is that the democracy part
is actually the challenging bit because
even in a world we might call socialist
in an economy that is not capitalism as
we know it we'd still have to balance
these factors we'd stuff to figure out
well when is coercion legitimate or when
can people choose right
when do we marshal the expertise of that
only a few people have and when do we
you know harness public opinion right
when how do we balance the needs of
people who live today with people who
have not yet been born so the
the book and in that I think when we
look at things that way we can say okay
well democracy is something that you
know it's a constant negotiation we have
to constantly reinvent it we have to
constantly think of new well who is the
people and how do they role and so I
don't think that you know socialism is
this magic word that would solve all of
our problems my attitude is that
actually if we had a more economically
fair system if we had a system where we
finally had you know political equality
we were where we understood women are
equals of men and black people are equal
to white people and you know people
without papers are equal to people with
papers if we finally had that kind of
equality that democracy actually
requires and the economic equality to
support that political equality then
we'd actually get to have really really
interesting democratic debates because
then we'd have to think about things
like well how do we have contrada we
have communities that have say over the
decisions that affect them that have
influence over the decisions that affect
their lives while also taking into
account the broader world right how do
we balance the needs of the present and
those who are not yet born right that's
the problem with climate change so I
think that um democracy is always going
to be it's always going to be difficult
and but hopefully those challenges will
just get more interesting yeah I in
thinking about the broader world I mean
I hesitate to talk about the the anytime
you introduce the term what is natural I
mean remember the around the gay
marriage debate how problematic that
concept of what if what is natural was
but to think at least hypothetically for
a moment is the idea of people being
democratic a natural or an unnatural
idea when we think back to humans like
in a state of nature hypothetically so
when you think about how humans interact
at some of those smaller scales in bands
of a few families is what might work or
not work they're not necessarily
relatable or translatable to populations
of millions or even hundreds of millions
of people as we now have in some of the
larger countries it's a saluted question
given the history of political
philosophy right yet always invoked the
state of nature this hypothetical
situation where you know people were
either warring and defensive in a
Hobbesian sense or actually living in
peace without private property and a
Rousseau Ian
that's why I say I'm curious about that
I'm wondering if it's even the right
question to be I want to read a relevant
question I think it's you know I think
well it's interesting to me the way you
know political philosophy promotes
different ideologies and and it comes
and moments of political rupture and and
helps people think through the problems
of their day I would frame things
differently I mean I think if you look
at human history there's all this
contradictory evidence right the history
of democracy is you know a history of
colonial conquest imperialism I mean
it's it's we live in a nation that calls
itself the land of freedom that was
founded on the ultimate form of
unfreedom slavery you know people have
made really terrible choices in the in
in the past but you know then you can
also look back at human democratic
history and see that there are all sorts
of wonderful advances right that people
have had solidarity they've stood up for
each other that actually this circle of
inclusion is you know expanding even if
it's it's imperfect and and and
sometimes progress goes into reverse so
I I think the jury you know is still out
and that we shouldn't extrapolate too
much from sort of you know some idea of
a state of nature
I liked it from the question actually to
go back to Rousseau in terms of what was
called the founding paradox and it's
this founding paradox of political
philosophy and it's how do you make a
democratic people out of an undemocratic
people and you know if we don't
naturally inclined towards you know
democracy especially in a modern
industrial you know global system like
the one we live in what we have to do is
we have to create the conditions for us
to be democratic through culture through
education through organizations of
solidarity we have to nurture a
democratic ethos and that's our
challenge I think as as part of the many
as part of regular part of a community
of regular people I think we also live
in a system where the powerful have
exactly the opposite agenda what they
want to do is create an undemocratic
people out of a democratically spirited
people so that's why you know famously
in the late sixties you know Sam
Huntington and others said there was a
crisis of democracy when when youth were
revolting and and and there was too much
sort of labor unrest but they were like
oh no there's you know for elites when
there's too much talk
it's a crisis they want people to become
more undemocratic more complacent so you
know I think we are we are certainly
standing in a moment where there's a
kind of democratic inclusion that that
people not that long ago would have
thought was you know impossible right
I mean people said you know women were
totally incapable of a rational judgment
participation and needed to have their
husband speak for them so we don't know
what's possible and I think invoking
human nature is yeah often a not the
best way to go how can we interpret in
thinking about this issue what we now
know to be a reality that often
democracies can make the wrong choices
or at least uninformed choices or
sometimes ignorant choices or whatever
the case may be and whether we apply it
to the current administration or
whatever else it doesn't really matter
but conceptually I mean even going back
to some of the older teachings that you
cite in your work there is this problem
where oftentimes the the populace the
more populous countries will have
uprisings or social social moves or
changes that lead to bad decisions being
made within the system how should we
think about that more broadly at a
political philosophy level yeah I mean I
think it's a risk that we have to take I
would never argue that democracy isn't
risky the demos can make bad choices but
I think just you know again just as we
might say okay there's all this evidence
that we can't trust the demos that they
are this unruly mob Plato warned of you
know that the democracy marginalizes the
wise and the virtuous which is what he
said in the Republic yes we also have to
say the best ideas about democracy came
from people came from people who were
excluded right when women said we should
be included as equal citizens they were
outside the community outside the
political community ideas about what
democracy could be have always come from
the margins from oppressing and
outsiders and the other thing is that
you know we've we've tried technocracy
that sort of been what we've the system
you know that's some people talk about
neoliberal capitalism is one where the
technocratic the experts in charge and
and they'll make decisions and you know
we've what we've had as a intense you
know escalation in terms of the
concentrate
of wealth we've had you know systems
emerge that are you know too big to fail
accept the fact they can fail what we're
facing is a climate crisis that even
though the science says this is going to
be devastating in fact it already is
devastating for for communities climate
change is happening now you know we seem
unable to stop it so you know putting
experts in charge you know and dimin you
know diminishing the power with people
hasn't worked either so that's where I
think we have to again create structures
where people can can become more
informed this is why education is so
central to to the democratic project we
also have to create a media ecosystem
that has positive incentives before this
book I wrote a book called the people's
platform about the political economy of
the internet and how you know so much
the problem with it is that the
incentives are all towards clickbait and
fast turning content because you know
it's the the business model is
advertising is is is data collection
right so you know we're we're we're we
have to address these sort of underlying
economic arrangements that shape our
culture and in and you know distort our
democracy so we have to be holistic and
and have a complicated analysis but I
don't think the I don't think we can can
write off the people especially because
working-class people have been have been
again at the forefront of pushing for
things like public education pushing for
the right to be not just workers but
part of part of a philosophical public
right that that is is essential to
democracy yes and as my audience has
been hearing for the last month in
particular we really should do what we
can to separate the media landscape from
a dependence on ad revenue because it
does I totally agree the wrong
incentives fundamentally people have
it--people had this fight with you know
television we had the fight with radio
this is where we're not an unprecedented
territory right people said the media
landscape is being distorted by these
incentives and they pushed for Public
Television they push for controls on
advertising we need to do the same in
the digital sphere
completely agree we have been speaking
with Astra Taylor who
is an author and documentary filmmaker
the dira she is the director of the film
what is democracy and author of the book
democracy may not exist but we'll miss
it when it's gone a so great to talk to
you today hey thanks for having me on
the David Pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so the clowns over at FoxNews are just
absolutely thrilled that we live in a
country where people are free to work
multiple jobs because one job doesn't
give them a stable a standard of living
there's this concept called freedom from
versus freedom to that exists in
political philosophy and it relates the
positive and negative freedoms okay so
positive Liberty is the freedom to do
something and negative Liberty is the
freedom from being stopped by other
people from doing something so the point
is there's different types of Liberty
and sometimes the freedom to do
something is actually only relevant
because there's a lack of freedom
somewhere else so here's an example if I
say it's great to have the freedom in
the United States to work for whichever
company gives you the best health
insurance a counterpoint would be hold
on a second it's terrible to lack the
freedom in the United States to be able
to just work whatever job is the most
rewarding job without being constrained
by worrying about losing your health
insurance that's the way I would see it
okay this gets us to Fox News now if I
said to you if you look at the numbers
of people in the United States who are
working multiple jobs is that a form of
freedom to work as many jobs as you want
or is that actually a reflection of the
lack of freedom that stagnant wages and
a lack of living wages place on people
and force them into having to work
multiple jobs
I consider the working multiple jobs
thing an indicator of the lack of
freedom that too many workers in the
United States experience which gets us
to the Fox News perspective on this
issue where absolute and total farcical
clowns Pete hagseth and Ainsley Earhardt
are just gushing they're literally
thanking God about how wonderful it is
that we live in a country where people
can work multiple jobs and it's it's
mind-blowing that this is actually an
analysis that resonates with millions of
people in this country take a look you
know you know what cobble hare says is
so it's so disingenuous for most of my
life I've worked two or three or four
types of jobs of sources of income today
you can do that more fly
simply how many people do you know who
do something and then maybe in their
free time they drive an uber or they do
something else to bring an extra cash
thank God we live in the kind of country
where we have the innovation and
flexibility where you can bring in money
from different things when I'm in an
uber and you talk to them you get to
know um many of them do say they're
doing this to make a little extra money
and we start talking about how much
extra do you mind if asked do you make a
week and it's it's enough to pay for
their kids to take an extra swim class
this one guy told me or it's enough to
put a little bit of money aside for
their kids to go to college I love those
types of people my dad worked several
jobs if you had the opportunity to make
a little extra he would these people are
truly sick I mean it's it's not
inspiring that so many people have to
work second jobs and third jobs it would
be inspiring to live in a country where
people didn't have to do that right this
is like those supposedly heartwarming
inspirational stories about how great
Americans are because when Little Jimmy
needed a prosthetic leg because of a
medical condition Jimmy's classmates and
teachers came together to fundraise and
do bake sales to raise money what a
great country
no no it's disgusting that one of the
richest countries in the world makes the
reality one where Jimmy couldn't just
get the prosthetic leg and needed money
from his classmates and from teachers
and from the parents of classmates
buying muffins at a bake sale it's
backwards okay and I actually want to go
further this multiple job status quo
that's so common actually reinforces the
system we have I've talked about this in
my segments about types of activism that
go beyond just signing a petition or
calling your elected official I've said
before corporations have huge
disproportionate control over our
systems the legal system the judicial
system media everything they maintain
control in part by making sure that
there's a system in which the average
person doesn't go protest doesn't demand
change doesn't participate in strategic
defaults or mass rallies in urban
centers and one of the best ways to make
sure people don't do that that people
don't protest and people don't demand
change
is if they can't even miss a day of work
because that would be two or three jobs
that they might get fired from or they
can't miss a day of work because they
can't buy food if they miss that day of
work that's a really great way to make
sure people don't show up and actually
protest and demand real change and if
you're in a situation where you even
need multiple jobs then you are very
unlikely to have the wherewithal and
resources to go in protest and demand
changes to the system that caused you to
need two or three jobs in the first
place this is a self-reinforcing
feedback loop and I mean listen I don't
know the Fox News hosts who said it's
just so inspiring to live in a country
thank God we live in a country where
people can work ten jobs if that's what
they want to do they may be useful
idiots they may be actual cogs in the
wheel deliberately reinforcing the
system it doesn't really matter okay the
effect is that they are reinforcing the
system that big corporations have
already done a pretty damn good job at
reinforcing really disturbing and
disgusting stuff I've been telling
anybody that will listen that Mitch
McConnell is almost as important as
Donald Trump to remove in 2020 McConnell
is a Republican senator from Kentucky
he's the Senate Majority Leader he has
been a really effective Republican
legislator and when I say that I'm
praising him only in the fact that he's
been able to achieve so much not that
he's achieved anything I like I think
his achievements have been wholly
destructive actually but he has been
effective in a way that is
extraordinarily detrimental to the
country and I would argue that it is
nearly as important to remove him in
2020 as it is to remove Donald Trump and
Mitch McConnell now has a 2020
challenger who I'm going to tell you
about in a second now in what ways has
McConnell been effective he's been
affected effective for a decade in
significantly pushing the US judiciary
to the right and this ranges from lower
courts all the way up to and including
the Supreme Court you might remember
notably at the end of Barack Obama's
presidency Merrick garland was nominated
by Barack Obama to the Supreme Court and
Mitch McConnell was able to successfully
Stonewall that nomination not even hold
confirmation hearings and that led
directly to Donald Trump getting an
additional
Supreme Court pick once he became
president and was inaugurated and that
is a decade lot that's a that's a win
for the right that will pay dividends
for decades long after Mitch McConnell
was gone
Mitch McConnell has been obstructing all
attempts to secure the 2020 election
from foreign interference Mitch just
isn't gonna have it okay and meanwhile
Mitch is taking money from lobbyists for
the biggest voting machine manufacturers
in the United States now I could go on
and on but this guy's toxic he's a truly
negative influence on our country on our
society on our culture on our economy
Aimee McGrath is a retired fighter pilot
a Democrat a former Marine and she is
taking on Mitch McConnell now back in
2018 in the midterms she tried to defeat
Republican congressman Andy Barr that
was in the Kentucky 6th district it
didn't work ok
she certainly is a more moderate
Democrat than Bernie Sanders right but
this is Kentucky she's right on way more
issues than Mitch McConnell is right on
and this is a really big opportunity now
I also want to be realistic I don't want
to be negative but this is an uphill
battle knocking off an incumbent
Republican senator in a red state is
tough in general especially when a
president of the same party is up for
reelection as is the case in 2020 but it
is not impossible and even if Amy
McGrath ultimately doesn't win she may
be able to seriously damage Mitch
McConnell in the process and more
importantly she might be able to force
the National Republican Party to pour
money into keeping Mitch McConnell's
seat which is money that then will not
go to other candidates in other seats
which is a really good thing no matter
what now there are some factors working
against Mitch McConnell and in a
McGrath's favor number one Trump is not
popular and McConnell is certainly a
trump associated senator in many ways
number 2 McConnell is not actually that
popular McConnell's net approval is
minus 13 meaning 13 percentage points of
the population more disapprove rather
than approve of the job McConnell is
doing and understand that Kentucky is a
very red state Kentucky leans towards
Republicans by plus 23 and McConnell is
minus 13 okay that's a minus thirty-six
what's called popularity Above
Replacement Center
score now all of this considered the
unfortunate truth is that a lot of those
Republicans in Kentucky who disapprove
of Mitch McConnell just want a different
Republican they don't want a Democrat
and they would still choose McConnell
over a Democrat and we have only to look
at Alabama to understand how this works
in December of 2017 there was a special
election in Alabama where serial accused
sex assault or Roy Moore almost won
against Doug Jones and more lost not
because Republicans said hey let's vote
for Doug Jones Doug Jones won and Roy
Moore lost because some Republicans just
stayed home and remember more almost did
win Moore received forty eight point
three percent of the vote in that
special election in Alabama the
overwhelming majority of all Republican
voters who did choose to vote in that
election so let's see what happens it
would be a massive victory to remove
Mitch McConnell it would be good for
Aimee McGrath even if she's not the
progressive I'd like it would be good
for Aimee McGrath to replace Mitch
McConnell and we've got to understand
this is Kentucky it's not Massachusetts
it's not Vermont it's not California so
let's see what we can do to help
Aimee McGrath in this election we'll
talk about her more upcoming we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two David P this is I was hoping
that nobody would notice this but I am
increasingly getting more and more
questions about a video in which I
appear getting a massage take a listen
to this is for real
take a listen to this hey David I saw a
very disturbing picture of what appears
to be you laying on a massage table with
the masseuse sticking her hand under the
towel I saw it on the YouTube channel of
the progressive voice right I was
curious if you could let us know that is
thank you a big fan of the show yes of
course
yeah listen this so once again people
have been trolling the YouTube archives
I used to when I was like 21 22 maybe I
had a video production business we
produced a lot of instructional videos
ranging from everything from jewelry
making to
dog training - massage therapy and on a
very interesting day back in who knows
what year we did a massage therapy video
series for I believe it was for a how or
expert village and a masseuse customer
am a massage customer was necessary and
I played that customer so I'm not going
to link to this if people are really
curious they can look around and find it
but I can assure you it was all on the
up-and-up okay we've got a great bonus
show today we'll talk about Eric's wall
well ending his presidential campaign
obviously that makes sense and many
people should do the same thing there's
this really weird series of people who
are licking ice cream they're opening up
ice cream in in grocery stores and
licking it and closing it and putting it
away and one of them has been arrested
and we'll also talk about the economic
impact of a $15 minimum wage nationally
based on a new Congressional
Congressional Budget Office report
really interesting data all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership to
become a member
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
become a patron both will give you
instant access to the bonus show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you